there's dark matter I think so there's
also featuring dark matter and is that a
girl's name guy I'm not sure look at
pornhub is just falling apart on us
they're like a bunch of parody ok um
dark matter what is there's a thing that
people do like Jamie was on the phone
once getting some tech information from
this lady sounds like put her on
speakerphone while he's typing and she
had the most unknown you know that thing
that people do it's called up talk oh
yeah up talk is so annoying
Tech Talk yes there's a way that they
talk no they're in it's like a very
left-wing technologically savvy way of
talking up slope tech yeah yeah but it's
all tech people yeah but it becomes an
accent like if it was from Georgia or
something like that would be a
recognizable accent yeah like oh that's
how they talk in Maryland right I get
talked to someone from Baltimore
Baltimore Baltimore you know you know
Ryan Sickler Yes Mother he says
Baltimore Tuesday Tuesday Tuesday
Tuesday Tuesday yeah my friend John
Rollo shoutout to John Rael he's from
Baltimore they have that same kind of
it's a very cost --n very recognizable
at Boston's got that [ __ ] I go up top
recognizable way of talking that lets
you know that I'm going to agree with
everything that is in like the zeitgeist
of Swing progressive technology anything
about its in the cloud who does that the
best Fred Armisen I think does that the
best Armisen knows how to like Fred
Armisen is that you know port from
Portlandia okay what is she doing
let me hear unless they do it a lot I
think it's really annoying
talk to me now it's Connie Chung focus
on the positive things in yourself
that's supermodel Cindy Crawford she's
going to do it again oh I didn't have
the opportunities then the popular term
for it is up talking but you don't have
to be a fashion model or a teenager to
up talk came to Ikea because you can
hear it on commercials I mean it's kind
of
self-serve or even coming out of the
mouth of a doctor on the president's
health care task force because I see the
problem from a different point of view
she came up to the table and said my
name is Belinda dr. Cynthia McLemore is
a linguist in Philadelphia who's worked
extensively all right this from 94
that's how [ __ ] old this is
interesting
yeah intonation is way more exaggerated
now it's interesting what they were
talking about in 94 for attention which
is the kind of response people may think
that up talk conveys uncertainty but dr.
McLemore says it can be used in a number
of specific ways you can use the rice to
convey uncertainty you can use the rise
to hold the floor you can use the rise
to convey do you understand what I'm
saying or do you hear me or do you agree
with me or do you approve of me all of
those things that's very interesting
here in the language describe what it is
because they've been adopted see if you
can google Tech Talk up talks what I was
looking but see if he can finally go
because it's way more exaggerated now
and the people that you know who I'm
talking about the woman that was talking
to on the phone how crazy was she it was
weird
the way she was talking there's like a
presentation to Jayme bazaar
what kind of are you working on
behringer X and his two one six is that
it I felt like we were in a sketch when
she was talking to him like this is an
SNL but she had no answers for him so it
was like she was like bullshitting him
well that's just played that's to
placate to past time that's not getting
about anybody in that tech world that
like anyone that's helping you with like
any sort of troubleshooting
I find that too when I do that on with
Apple when I text them about issues
everything is like this weird placating
like oh I know I can't believe you're
having that problem well let's just
figure out it's almost like this like
having you on the head like subservient
like yeah you okay in your pond do you
need more food in your pod Oh having
that issue with the Sonos player it's
all Apple all all Apple Apple has a
sneaky you know the Sonos thing works
flawlessly with the Apple music service
like hey for yep flawless Spotify but
when you try to get the [ __ ]
off your phone that's when a problem so
they've done some sneaky [ __ ] forced you
into that yeah that forces you into
using them their subscription service
sir
so they've hijacked so knows they've
done some [ __ ] where they've inserted a
little [ __ ] to you into the codes Apple
dick did they make it work better with
their home pod speaker of course works
come on it's a much better alternative
what we suggest you know you could you
switch over to home pod and that way you
can listen to everything you say all the
time we're listening in even when you
mute us we'll just released a new one
they released a pixel three with a new
speaker dock [ __ ] of a thing
that the new update on Spotify has a
built-in thing so you could it's so you
can like ask for a song we played yeah
because it's not probably built into
yeah but you have to like allow the
microphone to be on of course it's not a
big issue it's Joe and I listen to you
jerk off did you let do you allow the
microphone to be yeah um why is there a
piece of tape over the camera we'd like
to see your car I'd like to see you on
the webcam I want to see your car you
see that's only the back of your dick
it's not even the front is the front
facing you what's the big deal I took
the phone under my car what's the big
deal if I see your balls yeah that's
what I do I put the camera right under
my sack yeah I rest my red screen of my
[Laughter]
balls like him you drape your balls like
over look through my lens [ __ ]